what's up everybody and welcome to fight
week okay let's go
[Applause]
UFC 281 our boy Izzy about to knock this
dude the [ __ ] out uh Shadow realm time
for Alex Pereira it's definitely gonna
happen so we had to Big up the fight as
much as we possibly could you know
there's a UFC fight in our city how
often does that happen almost never
almost never so we got to make sure
that's the only place that we have UFC
and they gotta check in you know back
who are they trying to check in with who
they got to check in with greatest MMA
journals of all
[Music]
anyway so we're out here we got some of
the homies to pull up man some of the
absolute flagrant fan favorites this
first guy coming in right now
he broke my heart man what why well he
broke my heart because as much as I love
him I also like the guy that he just
fought and dominated a couple fights ago
and it broke my goddamn [ __ ] heart
yeah I remember that but I still love
him he's a wild boy last time he came on
the podcast he made news he he literally
added a word to the vocabulary yeah he
did you know what I'm saying we still
use today to this guy that action that
you used last night 100 that's all you
do that I'm bubbling him up
listen my wife trying to get pregnant
I'm bubbling wow
oh wait what are you oh it's with P
You're supposed to no no no no no no no
no no ejaculate oh God you got you all
I'm trying to say is we got the great
Alexander Vulcan now
all right
ready
that's good now this is perfect now do
you realize how how uh powerful that
last podcast was when you came on how
powerful how powerful it was like I
heard you give it on the intro were you
sort of uh gave me a little rundown of
how it was there were obviously a new
word that I I knew straight away what
you were talking about and well that's
the thing now people are pissing in
their mouths Because of You Across the
Nation because of you yeah awesome about
just an Aussie thing now right no dude
Mr worldwide that's you yeah it's a
Tick-Tock yeah we're appropriate
I don't know if it's that much to be
proud of but I mean I thought I am you
know what I mean I mean listen it
doesn't taste great but it's a fun
little party favorite I will be honest
so so we thought it'd be a great idea if
in your next fight
come on bro in between rounds what could
be more intimidating oh yeah yeah like
you're like I need something to drink
and then you just knock the water bottle
away whip out your [ __ ] Bubble Up yeah I
can't help can you imagine that hey
imagine that I tell you what though like
you know I mean like you know what they
say you know when you're putting your
fluids back in water and that you should
have at room temperature exactly because
yeah you absorb it a lot quicker and I'm
guessing the the flow is already the
right temperature right so you're going
to soak that [ __ ] up straight away
science baby that is science I think
Andrew huberman actually said that I
think he's a neurobiologist and he was
like you got to Bubble Up if you really
want to get your [ __ ] to homeless a
neurobiologist
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that aren't exactly terms
um you got a big fight coming up man
yeah yeah well uh you know obviously
it's not locked in yeah you know what I
mean but it's not like well it's not a
nice finder on paper being I mean like
uh well we we're going to make it happen
anyway so obviously there was a lot of
people like you know what's going on
yeah but we'll make it happen now when
you're pound for pound number one right
when you pound profile number one is the
money a little bit a little different is
it
oh man there's a lot more opportunities
that come with it look man for me
yeah
opportunities
can I get some opportunities hey look to
be honest
in your mouth there's a future
obviously being a champ obviously that's
that comes with opportunities too but
the whole power for pound sort of thing
is like yes
I'm not any different right I'm the same
guy but yeah yeah you know it does make
it has a ring to it a lot of people you
know what I mean like I thought temp was
good enough but once those powerful
pound everyone's like [ __ ] we want a
piece of y'all really all right sweet so
like like getting back home like Brands
and [ __ ] they're trying to reach out
like yeah like you end up getting yeah
just it's I don't know I think it's just
the
I don't know though the champ I guess
there's a few of them powerful pound
they can only say that to one person so
they make sure they every time they
introduce it that's got to be there you
know what I mean they're Barefoot down
you know so it sounds good and I know
people just love it and yeah
opportunities opportunity now I know
you're happily married you have children
Etc but the DM's got to be crazy
just the DMS it's not like you look at
like you know you just look he doesn't
you don't check bro you might open it up
but not like accept it you know I'll
just go through okay but look at this
that's funny your wife's name is Emma
but so is mine okay so when you first
said I was like
you keep your pounding for pounding over
there
oh that's gold now but yeah that's what
that says sometimes you do obviously you
know it's a it's social media it's the
internet shit's gonna yeah you're gonna
get some weird [ __ ] sent here I'm sure
you [ __ ] know about that as well yeah
yeah yeah so like sometimes I just we
have a laugh about I go check this out
oh really you just scroll the DMS I'm
not really leave it here and there you
just flip flick floor right you know it
catch the big crazy sometimes there are
so hard I want to get back to people you
know what I mean but you know someone's
sending a you know a gaping hole or
something yeah I don't want nothing to
do it you know
but I do sometimes it can be not yeah it
ain't a woman every time
one of your teammates or something
trying to prank but it's Monday boys
oh no I just just take it to peace now
now do any of the guys that you played
rugby with do any of the because I
imagine like you're a competitor
probably the boys are lucky and they go
mate don't tell them everything we
[ __ ] do
I said it's a I don't know where we're
from and all that it's a bit of the the
culture you know we have a laugh it's
not like you know that every day they're
sitting there pissing in their mouths
you know yeah it's not like every one of
my friends though it's not like we all
do it yeah it's just it's it's happened
before right it takes yeah you know I
mean it's funny because we make it look
like every Aussie pisses in their mouth
but I mean they don't really like that
but yeah yeah
um
the fact you've got to say it's not yeah
right makes me think every Australian
[Laughter]
it's probably more regular than it
should be anyway yeah 100 no but the
guys that used to play rugby with you
would probably imagine you're
competitive you would talk [ __ ] maybe
you would kind of like scrap at them a
little bit not serious fights but you
know these are guys you're playing a
sport every once in a while things get
heated oh man no not really like we used
to like it back when we were playing
football like you would always uh yeah
again Mad Mondays everything will happen
so uh we'll just here start wrestling
and yeah just doing like you know
everyone goes oh let's do it then the
next minute people are just running like
remember they're proper cooked like
they've been going for a couple of days
and then they're just running at each
other remember no just in their undies
actually yeah because we call it no Andy
Mundy
so you're not allowed to wear undies
you're actually not around La so you've
got to wear shorts and if you're wearing
undies they just rip them straight off
so we call them no Andy Mundy so you
could imagine uh the boys uh
doing proper hit UPS you know what I
mean you know lining up you know shirts
off and wearing footy shorts with no
undies so you know the Junk's moving
around yeah so they're just they're
running straight at each other bang and
you're just saying heads arms and balls
just flying in here it's [ __ ] crazy
how is that uh how are those Samoan uh
Roots dude do they got big dicks what's
that story the Samoan guys do they have
big dicks I'm from Australia we do have
plenty of Samoans there but yeah what
are they are they known for big dicks
yeah I don't know but they're not Hawker
they just whack their dick on their legs
I've got a lot of Simone friends that'll
say yes just to do their most followers
just want to go back well you [ __ ]
just say yes that's what you have to do
oh yeah yes yes I won't say no because
I'm gonna [ __ ] hear about it okay so
after you beat Islam we all go for a
Monday uh fun day I mean this sincerely
I would cut I would come to Perth stop
it watch the fight obviously we support
you but I want to do a Monday no no one
day Monday not a one day Monday
Sandy because it's the honor it's a
Sunday Monday will be actually Sunday
and then the next day is a Monday so you
guys would fight in the morning yeah
that's great the way you did the days
yeah that was super good yeah man yeah I
still got it yeah don't ever let them
tell you
I'll do it if you're there I'm gonna
have to make it happen you could not
hang bro because I know all my I know
all my footy mates are going to be there
so is that nerve-wracking well having
everyone there yeah it's no no no not to
me really look uh
for me I'm I adapt to whatever situation
I'm really good at doing that yeah so I
can turn everyone booing at me which
obviously I did in the last month I've
had that a couple of times I'm not
fighting home always an enemy territory
you could say and being booed and I can
just turn that into a positive for me
I'll just make it work for me like I'll
just sit there going oh yeah like I'm
getting bored usually a lot of people
like yeah and I'm like Oh and it fires
me up I'd be like okay I'm gonna show
you this I mean like it's a it's weird
as like I know they're gonna boo so I
started being like even if you see me
walk out in the last one
uh I was prepared for them to boo
because they already booed me a little
bit here and there yeah oh it's on my
phone
um yeah already prepared that they were
going to boomi and things like that so
I'm walking out and you see me on the
camera I'm like oh I know they're born
doesn't matter I know you're watching
back home I'm talking to everyone back
home I know you're watching I know you
supported and it was like firing me up
like because I I do that I was like
these guys are gonna go I'm gonna have
to oh you know what what we said
actually because uh me and easy hold the
line hold the [ __ ] line you know what
I mean we're like [ __ ] them like you
know they can boo they can all come at
us but let's hold the [ __ ] because I
was like that I was like let's do it do
you enjoy being the the villain a little
bit well I I I I love being like the
underdog and yeah the villain maybe not
that villain but I mean if people are
going to boo again I'm going to make it
work you know I'm I'm a people pleaser
right so that should show you that booze
should affect me yeah but I can switch
it around and be like nah [ __ ] you and
have one of the best performances of my
life so and then get people tearing but
that's the thing about it it's like if
you're used to being the underdog right
if you're used to people not expecting
you to do the things you've done like
you've you were playing rugby against
these guys they were I know you were way
much more at that time but when they
first look at you like they're not going
oh yeah this is exactly how I imagine a
rugby guy and then dominating right like
win the championship man of the match in
the championship so like I'm wondering
if it's harder for you when people are
going he is the pound per pound he is
the guy is this the first time in your
life that now everybody's going nobody
can beat him well like uh well yeah
because I've always been that dog even
when I was a champion they'll still you
know you're going to be doubters but
maybe you know here I am calling for the
the Laraway Champion you know against a
guy like Islam you know that everyone's
like oh yeah what about the rest of the
Lord now the doubting me again I'm like
thank you exactly you know that's what
maybe that's what I'm chasing maybe I'm
chasing it I'll be honest that's what I
thought like where am I if You Raise Me
Up you could have stayed in the division
continue to dominate but maybe part of
you is like I need the challenge to get
me [ __ ] going look it excites me this
one excites me yeah I'm fired right up
yeah yeah yeah I was talking a couple of
boys uh back out back and I was saying
like
man uh it made me realize how much I
wasn't fired up for like even the max
fights yeah right now I'm doing so many
different things again again I need to
put on some muscle and I've got a new
diet now I need to focus on a specific
thing where the last few fights I just
had to work on my game obviously I had
to focus on something but not real Focus
right now it's just mainly focused we
know what he wants to do he wants to
wrestle he wants to wrestle he's going
to want to hold me down I'm very I never
really had to worry about but you would
have been running I'm very good at I'm
very good at takedown defense very hard
to hold down yeah so I don't really ever
need to train too much of that I've just
had that like and that's not something
like if they get me down I'm like I know
I bounce back up yeah we've hit a guy
like him as far as member goes hey
people think they won't be up I'm like
mate put it this way
this is this is what a lot of people ask
me how you're going to deal with the
rest of them like no I'm gonna get up
everyone's trying to say that he is a
so well-rounded I'll I'm going to test
that that's the test that I want to see
I want to see how well Around It is Well
I'm going to get back to my feet it's
going to be a stand-up battle yeah he
had a one good punch against Charles now
everyone thinks he's a striker right
we'll see yeah yeah because it's harder
to hit you yeah exactly it's interesting
yeah and I've got nothing nothing
against Charles yeah but you know I
ain't gonna stand in front of you and
come aggressively and give you give you
them opportunities I'm going to hit you
yeah and I'm going to be completely
[ __ ] gone you have you have an
amazing ability to maintain distance
especially when you're at a size
disadvantage but your [ __ ] arms are
long yeah so it's not always a size
disadvantage right like and I wonder if
that's from training with taller guys
like I've seen you in Izzy Spar like you
know just friendly kind of like sparring
the gym and I'm just like what a great
thing that is to deal with a guy who's
all arms and legs and be able to manage
that distance and find a way to get
inside and then get out before because I
saw and I broke my heart because I
[ __ ] love Max as well but it was like
he just couldn't time you because
couldn't get out something changed from
fight two to three yeah well look we had
a decent game plan as well right so we
knew sort of where he would want to uh
go with that we we thought it would come
aggressive we knew what he did well in
the second fight and that he would want
to do again so we just took away a
couple of those things and then plus the
footwork and me leveling up and all
those things just made it uh too much
for him like I was just always out of uh
I was always in position for me and he
was always out of position I just had
him adjusting the whole time even though
he's trying to walk me down you know he
couldn't get to a position where I was
Square in front of him for square in
front of him for him to set me up and
land some [ __ ] you know he might have
had one punch and I was already gone and
you'd have to reset and I'm just making
him pay every single time and beating
him yeah yeah exactly yeah man like so
he I said as I was getting him in I was
making him you know kind of give away
everything but yeah yes but you know
like while I was doing all that if he
yeah wanted to come in a little bit
aggressive of making pay yeah uh then he
would like even him just adjusting I'll
make him pay you know even if he did get
in I'll win that exchange anyway making
pay so so it's just I was just winning
absolutely yeah applying pressure in
literally every Avenue yeah man just uh
no matter what he tried
I just were like no not today okay so
with the Islam fight you you're gonna
make sure it stays on the feet
now people go these guys are so strong
they understand they're like the
dagestanis they're like weight and
balance is good and it's undeniable
they've had a lot of success what I
wonder is with you because you've come
down so much in weight if you're used to
being with guys that are applying that
type of weight whereas a guy like
Charles maybe isn't used to wrestling
with or trying to move a man that's 180
590 pounds usually walking yeah look
look I'm sure he trains with big guys I
sure he could handle it but the thing is
he thinks I can't handle it right that's
where he's going to get [ __ ] up with
you know I mean like he's going to
realize like if he's literally thinking
that he's just because he's bigger than
me he's just gonna hold me down like and
everyone that trains to me goes oh man
look that ain't gonna be easy especially
now when I've got to focus all this time
and attention to it mate this is I'm
gonna be a complete problem to hold down
trust me and that's something that if
he's really thinking it's going to be an
easy process mate he is gonna he's gonna
struggle mentally once he realizes that
I get bounced back up and I'm popping
him in the face with some Jabs and big
shots and I'll be like oh and I [ __ ]
told you you know what I mean and just
watch that's what I want to see
everyone's like oh how are you going to
prove that I'm going to be watching him
because I know even if he does get me
down even if he is holding me down I
ain't gonna lose composure yeah I'll be
in there that's all good I'm fine that
I'll just keep fighting till he slows
down whatever I'm going to be okay I
know what if things don't go away he
wants them to
he's not gonna like that now all of a
sudden he's uncomfortable man I put
myself in uncomfortable positions
all the time you know what I mean that's
what made me who I am bring it on yeah
it's Monday
the training room and it has come time
how big are you getting up to uh look
not only look the White's probably going
to sit the same as how it is now but
we're just trying uh the calories
obviously you need to eat so many
calories just to to build some of that
muscle and stuff like that I want to
obviously cut the fat and then just hold
muscle so the the weight won't be too
much different okay maybe a couple kilos
if that but um well pounds of maybe five
pounds or something like that but I want
to make it all muscle and you know lose
the fat and just make sure that every
bit of weight that I do have is you know
yeah you know like an ideal weight not
just a bit of water a bit of fat yeah
yeah yes I'll be very lean uh come come
fight time now do you worry about an
over focus in the wrestling discipline
like you know that that's what he's
going to do so you're preparing but you
still don't want your timing to be off
you don't want so you have to balance
that yeah man 100 so that's uh and
that's something I'm always going to
fight my style so that's another thing
like yeah I'm going to put a lot of
drilling sessions right specific
sessions but when in the fighting is
happening oh like uh yeah but every
other like I do all sessions all the
time you know what I mean so I'm
constantly working striking and I'm
constantly doing pads with Joe and
that's where we do a lot of our movement
and a lot of that stuff so that I do
that even now I just stay on top of all
that always you know what I mean because
that's that's where that's money for me
yeah that's that's where I get you know
that's where I give people most problems
yeah but I mean now it's just a lot of
the attention like uh is now just more
takedown defense and all that type of
stuff a lot of the drilling uh is going
to be focused around that but then I'm
going to have my pad sessions my
sparring yeah striking sessions that's
going to be all our stand up anyway love
so that's another thing that uh and
another thing for me is that I want to
get everything on point where I'm not
worrying about the takedown exactly so
I'm I'm drilling all that yeah but I
mean when I'm standing with him I'm not
sitting there like oh watch out for take
him
[ __ ] him up he gets on my hips I'll
worry about it then yeah yeah don't
worry I ain't gonna hesitate on his feet
just because you might come in I'll deal
with that when it happens yeah you deal
with ease first yeah yeah
I like the confidence so that's that's
that's the difference where a lot of
people are so worried about the takedown
which they can't even get in their game
yeah well like now they're like they're
hesitating that you know what I mean
like they do one false move you know
what I mean next minute they're getting
punch in the face yep next minute uh the
wrestlers bashing the the the uh the
striker on the feet because they're so
worried about the takedown yeah that's
not how long draw them into your game
yeah exactly I'm gonna fight my fight
and deal with uh you know my footwork
deals with a lot of that anyway it's
gonna make it hard for him to shoot but
if he gets through my hips I'll worry
about that then yeah but I mean uh
before that
he's got to worry about my hands I'm
excited man all right guys we gotta take
a break for a second because it's time
to get healthy okay we're gonna get
healthy the quick and easy way with one
delicious scoop of athletic greens one
ag1 right here you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals Whole Food
Source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help start your day right
okay this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging all the things
literally okay ag1 is a small micro
habit with massive benefits you're going
to be sleeping better the quality is
going to be so improved of your recovery
specifically the mental Clarity and
alertness you're gonna get and it costs
you less than three dollars a day you're
investing in your health and it's
cheaper than your cold brew habit think
about that right now
it's time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com flagrant again that
is athleticgreens.com flagrant to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional assurance
now let's get back to the show all right
man you know we have uh your boy is uh
is is with us right now I want to bring
him out uh Craig Jones is in the
building hopefully Craig is about to
walk through those stairs maybe it'll be
in a couple minutes but uh an amazing
Jiu Jitsu player I believe is how they
say it right yeah Jiu-Jitsu player yeah
Jiu Jitsu yeah you won't say photo no I
think I think it's or grab I think they
call them Jiu Jitsu players players oh
yeah yeah I mean that that sounds cool I
know we'll ask him when he comes out
yeah but I'm curious
dude
I don't tell you right now all right get
out of here all right
[Applause]
[Music]
Craig have a seat okay Craig is it Jiu
Jitsu player
it was definitely not jiu-jitsu fighter
you know what I mean we're helping each
other around or anything
so was I right
[Laughter]
now
I think so yeah when they're trying to
talk it up a bit making him a bit cooler
than what it is
isn't it Jiu Jitsu player practitioner
they said Craig is a player
explain something to me this is
something that I've seen oftentimes MMA
fights guys who are good Strikers
go to the ground
they can strike for five rounds it's
nothing
grappling cardio seems to be a
completely different animal
yeah well I think wherever you're
uncomfortable you're gonna make bad
decisions use sort of strength of a
technique and start to panic but myself
I'm not really one to talk because my
cardio is pretty terrible as it is oh
yeah when I go out there if I don't
finish within five minutes things are
going bad
my wife has said that about me yeah
so that's it you're going immediately
for the finish and then I go way too
high too early yeah myself kind of the
opposite to Volks here his gas tank
lasts forever yeah I've noticed it in
the ring you know yeah
now did you guys know each other before
like do you know each other from back
home well yeah like we do better from uh
like a bit of Jiu-Jitsu or while I was
in MMA but does he come to the camera
just [ __ ] you all up real quick yeah
yeah he does I mean that's what it
literally comes like he's been he's been
in the corner the last few times so
we've uh he did The Ultimate Fighter
with us as well yeah uh which we've got
a couple of cool stories with that one
as well but yeah he's coming down there
but that's usually how it is it comes in
and then just [ __ ] everyone is it that
easy
now he's getting better actually yeah
[Laughter]
it was like that because I mean if I go
then it'll be every minute I'm getting
tapped every minute really yeah I'll be
like I'm [ __ ] you know what I mean and
then it's slowly got less I wasn't every
minute the puppy you know well he's got
to build you up a little bit yeah yeah
you feel the confidence right yeah why
did he do that from this you're doing so
good yeah
perhaps in the 10 minutes I gotta make
it seem like he's improving yeah
that's right that's right yeah that's a
[ __ ] weird thing because I guess when
you're focused strictly on that
discipline
I guess that makes sense that you're
going to be so Elite at that skill that
nobody else is going to be able to
compete with you unless they do but I
think the perception oftentimes with MMA
like you see the guys who are black belt
what the [ __ ] is a black belt though
what does that mean like it seems like
there's guys that are black belts that
they they're like how do I say it like
the SATs is the SATs do you know what
that is like the test everybody takes
and if you get 100 on that you do it it
seems like there's different levels to
the black belts is that fair I would say
it's like a marketing strategy to hook
you into it you know what I mean if you
just show up to class and you don't get
rewarded with anything it's hard to keep
you in that but it's like a trick so you
get a blue belt you feel really good
so it's just marketing
did you give him a black belt no a Joe
gave you the black belt right yeah okay
that chill out there your dad my dad
your dad gave you a black belt right
there it's funny every time we're
walking around the UFC event there but
everyone always thought he was my dad a
hundred percent I mean I'm shocked he
can hold the mitts for you that guy like
he he holds it he gets handled really no
I have no there's no I mean he looks
like he's been on like a tuna boat for
like
[Laughter]
he's a tough looking monkey
I'm not going out there anymore until
Joe's out of here I thought you said
that's my paw and I was I was like I
haven't heard anybody call anybody
really people used to watch me because
fight week too like the intensity like
uh goes up like yeah I'm getting in my
[ __ ] zone right yes so I'm picking
him I'm bumping him around people like
[ __ ] yeah yeah or maybe I'm not not
as much anymore but I mean like yeah
only a couple years ago I was like
throwing him proper throwing him that
guy's 90 years old
you give me gold for the trip [ __ ]
yeah dude that's that's not allowed
that's a bad thing
no questions
[Music]
no there's no question because I shook
his hand and it was like oh you're a man
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's hot man we
freaking might even have like a he's
been toes uh he's gonna hate me for this
yeah has been told for a while and I'm
like [ __ ] gout for sure you know I'm
telling him like that and he's like from
drinking and stuff like taking the piss
but I think it might have been broken
for the last two three [ __ ] weeks I
think he's like broke his toe he's like
I saw him like oh man it should be
better by an hour no maybe you should
get it checked out you know
yeah maybe get an x-ray nope you do get
it checked out I'll give him that I'll
give him that he's a hard man he sort of
got it checked out yesterday we got into
the car with him today and he was
complaining about his big toe and he
said he had a guy pulling it yesterday
yeah
I know I could see him definitely
banging Asian hookers for sure like
that's a hundred percent like a couple
of trips out there you know
the whole Show's just talking about yo
joe you're the man don't come in here
don't come in here he loves it he loves
a bit of better too okay good now Craig
let me ask you a question The Ultimate
Fighter you come bust these guys asses
do they ever want to spar you to get
their get back Yeah we actually did this
right wait wait what happened
okay we did three rounds so we did a
grappling round yeah we did a wool
wrestling round and then we did a
striking round but 10 minute rounds of
each year seven minute rounds but um
no no no no I was no mercy at the start
yeah but I probably shouldn't have done
that because then we had to strike later
okay but I cheated when we're striking
he was beating me up a bit and I just
took him down
is actually footage of that like we got
footage of it like sitting there like a
I was like getting into it
all right next but he's just taking me
down and holding me down I'm like you
[ __ ] can't do this
come on SO women when you get a hold of
a dude
how how close do you need to be to be
dominant in other words like it's wrist
and then you can kind of wrap it up from
there or in terms of when we're on the
feet or when we're like if you and a guy
are on the street arguing you think the
guy's gonna get violent if I think I
might pull God at that point you go on
your back in the street come here Daddy
can I be honest with you
if you did that New York like it was a
bar fight in the middle of the bar you
just went on your back and you're like
come on
you never lose it
[Music]
dude that's a great way have you been in
a street fight
only one one only one ever but I've used
no jiu jitsu I just was punching on with
a guy but I don't even know how to
[ __ ] box or anything how did that go
down I want to know I haven't asked you
about this uh well we we slugged it out
for a bit and then he started running
away but he had like ripped my shirt in
the process I was pursuing him through
the streets for quite a long time and I
was like this looks terrible it's gonna
it feels very wrong pay me for my shirt
it was like at one point he jumped over
a fence and I ripped my pants as well
but he took a wrong turn so it was like
a horror movie he went around a corner
and he was trying to get into a door
that was locked yeah yeah he sort of
finished it up there but yeah um so so
all people really try to finish it in
the alleyway yeah pulled it straight out
I'm just saying like the average person
they see your shirt ripped and then your
pants ripped and you're chasing a guy
you know it doesn't look like uh it
looks like dotted it you know yeah yeah
it looks like it looks like a fun season
though right it's like a fun time that's
the reason
what happened what started the fight I
just left the club and he just hit me
and were you stealing him were you
stealing shorties nothing just left the
club I was only like 18 at the time up
in like uh what was it like sunshine
okay yeah and then I was just like that
sometimes he got to put mine in I was
like Bogan is he a Bogan I would say so
big time Bogan he was shirtless at the
time
you can't find a guy that's charged
journalists you know what I mean because
that means he's been in enough fights
and he's like I can't ruin the show yeah
yeah he thought you didn't think about
that yeah if you had thought about that
then you should wouldn't rip the [ __ ] up
is that what I look like yeah that's I I
know yeah because when I see him it's a
little intimidating when I see him
sitting in that chair I feel like that's
what I look like yeah yeah you look like
that yeah it's the same yeah build them
up Alice
thing let him get some time
so let's say and then can you do like a
real squeeze a real squeeze yeah like
okay
no I'm just saying because I that's the
thing right like once you lock in once
you grab you wouldn't want to give him a
hand that's it
so forearms are the same okay all right
chill
your arms are like the same size roughly
pretty much you know what I mean I feel
like that's the same build dude that's
me you feel powerful we can move that we
can actually move this dude and then do
a nice little thing right you see what
you did what you created what he think
he thinks he's this let him beat him
like if anyone wants it yeah what I mean
pull God someone start someone I will
pull I'll pull it do you guys ever pull
guard together and just bump up bubbles
so you guys is that a move unfortunately
it is yes
could you imagine that their luxury
glass shapes what you want to get you
want again they both just pop 2010.
[Laughter]
has it been crazy to see how popular Jiu
Jitsu has gotten in your professional
lifetime for sure because when I started
it wasn't even a career it was like an
exercise yeah I didn't even know what I
was doing at the time yeah I was like oh
yeah we'll do a few tournaments maybe
I'll teach some classes yeah but now
like you could be a full-time competitor
yeah you don't really even have to teach
yeah
and is that what you're doing right now
I try to do a bit of everything right
because it's like obviously
um competing all the time it's brutal
stuff on the body and stuff obviously we
don't get paid as much as the USD guys
yeah but uh so I try to balance it with
like uh instructionals uh sort of
running a gym a little bit and competing
as well yeah because you have to think
of also the exit strategy for the
professional career and if you're not
making like [ __ ] NBA money or
pound for pound money you know if you
don't have those opportunities it's
opportunities that's right yeah we're
learning we're getting media training
with Vulcan like yeah if you have all
these opportunities you've got to be
you've got to be clever mate he switched
on you know remember the guillotine with
Brian Ortega
choke the fence that's toke defense uh
was out the next day they're only like
the instructions
did you say just have a [ __ ] cylinder
for a head like that
stuff worked your whole life of having
no neck
I I used all the sound bites like Ortega
was like how the [ __ ] did he get out of
that truck bang turned it into an
instruction on that's the commercial
photo straight away did Ortega hit you
like you [ __ ] he didn't like me
on the show at all really at all but
I've since seen him then since then
we've been we've been pretty cool but we
played we played a prank on him that
really didn't go down wait what happened
well luck man if we actually there was a
couple of pranks that went down that he
was allowed to do whatever pranks he
wants but we weren't allowed a couple of
hours actually didn't make the show and
we weren't allowed to do okay so like
that's something like some of the things
like uh you only you've oh yeah they
tried they tried to fire me because we
had the covert testing at the time and
when I went into the office I saw uh I
guess the scrapers with everyone's name
on it okay so I took Ortega's and
pretended to stick it in my ass and put
it back
once the UFC go into that they were very
upset about it that was too vulgar for
them that was too much that's the Mad
Monday [ __ ]